i'm going to start with the one that
everybody's been having the hardest time
with
just three words to describe this season
oh god
oh my god yes oh my god ah it's really
tough dad docker um fractured and
intense and intense it is intense for a
number of reasons at the very at the end
of last season we had claire deal with
the um very traumatic event i say we
kill her leave her for the beasts you
know face has got his ass full for a
while
this still
gucci in your words you know what is she
going through well i think when we first
meet claire on the surface she's trying
to you know put a brave face on and go
about her daily life as if everything is
fine and everything's normal but really
underneath that she's really struggling
and
we explore the ptsd that she's
experiencing and we explore how
that trauma is affecting not only her
but the
the whole family and
and what her coping mechanisms are this
season i think you know prior to this
claire is someone who
has always been able to compartmentalize
things and put something in a box and
move on and that just doesn't serve her
this season we also have the i guess the
the newcomers to frasier's ridge and the
christie's said not to know for whom the
bell tolls
he told for thee
what sort of
uh i guess threat to the peace does tom
christie represent
to the rich we find out obviously the
prior relationship or
animosity i guess between the two or uh
this challenge of of power and christie
arrives and yeah it's a rather unwelcome
um arrival uh to the phrases ridge and
it really signals the beginning of this
sort of
unraveling i guess of the phrases
popularity at the ridge and also
um the status quo so
they are they all have their own
individual storylines um and
relationships but yes the the christie
family as a whole or
yeah they're not not the neighbor you
really want
no
because he really like
he
jamie puts it really well at the end of
the second episode which is you know he
wields a very powerful weapon that that
could really
turn people against them you know
especially with you know claire knowing
what she knows about
healing people and medicine and whatnot
it's like you know you could be very
easily be you know told you were a witch
and everybody would say
he seems to be a man of god he must know
what he's talking about yeah he's got a
lot of power and people follow him
and i think um they jump in there but i
think yeah he absolutely does and he's
you know jamie is quite forward thinking
quite a modern man but i think there are
people that obviously would have their
feet stuck in the past and would follow
tom yeah i guess it's that religious
fundamentalism you know that he he
wields
and and it's very unaccepting of
women or any kind of modern forward
thinking and um
as sam said you know it's a very
dangerous thing that he he kind of holds
over people as we sort of barrel towards
the american revolution here
you know what do you think claire's
headspace is about
the the safety of her family and the
rich and the people around her because
as we know it's you know we know how how
it goes or she it's she knows how it
goes yeah you know unfortunately she
knows the outcome but uh it's all those
really important steps that lead up to
it that she's not so clear on which
would be much more helpful to them um
you know i think it's a really it's a
really tough position that they're in
you know i think jamie carries sort of
the the larger brunt of that burden
the titus turned king's counting on you
mr fraser
all right gonna be two things at once
clear
a rebel
a loyalist
agent for the crown and an enemy of the
king
you can't live your life afraid of being
who you are
with having to decide where his
loyalties are his allegiances are at any
given time because they know that at a
certain point they're going to have to
go against the crown
but at this present point the crown is
who kind of rules the law and and you
have to appease them and you have to be
seen to be
um loyal to the crown at this point and
so it's a really it's a really delicate
balancing act that they're trying to um
trying to do at the moment talk to me
about the balancing act of shooting
while
undercover precautions
your pregnancy and still wanting to keep
the show
sexy
you know the the legacies are still like
they're still there no i think we we
absolutely
had a lot of challenges this season you
know as you said with the covert
protocols and obviously we kept everyone
safe but um they they did add an extra
level of i guess a challenge to your
everyday
working environment but also
you know katrina was pregnant which i
think was uh remarkable on her behalf
you know to be four five six months
pregnant um right towards the end when
we were doing all the action stuff so i
like
very super uh and it was the height of
winter in scotland you know it was we
don't we don't normally shoot um through
those months so um it was it was tough
but uh but i think you know we have such
a great crew now and cars that everyone
just mocks in and gets on with it i kept
waiting for the shots of like
of claire holding like a lampshade or a
box or something or you know but you
guys covered it very very well um oh
they'll be coming
how how are you feeling i have an eight
month old so i'm i'm i know
kind of roughly what's going on in life
how are you feeling are you good are you
like are you nodding off in between each
one of these interviews
i'm exhausted i think you you know
exactly what i feel like
um but it's great you know i have this
beacon of hope that i'm gonna gonna have
a full night's sleep at some point this
year um and when that comes i'm gonna
i'm gonna be like a new person um and
also i mean your other baby this year
belfast is like people are in love with
it
[Music]
award nominations are starting to roll
in and i know people actors always say
it's not about that we don't do it for
that but if there were one that would
like really mean a lot to you
which one would it be oh god um
you know i think i think actually we we
got an ensemble nom for sag which i
think has meant a huge amount to all of
us i think it's like
we were a really tight-knit group um
making this
it felt very special when we were all
together and the fact that we've got
like kind of a group um
recognition feels really really good